uh
subscribe hey how many only fans
accounts have you subscribed to so far
lot you so you're a supporter of yes
it's kind of
do you do you look at it like better
than porn because you feel like you kind
of like
the girls like accessible right it's
almost like you know them
facts yeah i feel like i could [ __ ] you
so why not get a preview like put some
money in your pocket
like and it helped like yo like i
so like boom let me see like what she
like
working with for a [ __ ] um so have you
ever
subscribed to a woman's only fans
account and then [ __ ] her after
yes nice multiple times yes
what do you dmr honestly know what
though or on ig and say yo i support
what you're doing
but you know what though [ __ ]
i just linked with a girl
not too long ago [ __ ]
her only fans ain't looking like her in
person
in a bad way it's like you saw her in
person you're like yo what's up
got a catfish on the only family got
catfished did you still [ __ ] though of
course you did no
no you didn't oh self-power self-control
rather
you've got to respect it gotta respect
it so only fans
i feel like is like the quarantined
strip club right better
it's better better so
yo yo the [ __ ] ain't them [ __ ]
they yo them [ __ ] ain't
ain't doing what they doing only fans in
the strip club
that's true they getting crazy i only
think
so i haven't subscribed to any only fans
accounts because i have
uh i'm just not i'm very frugal with my
money
man listen i feel like there's enough
free porn pornographic material in the
world
it's worth it i'm also a married man so
my wife would slice my throat
if she said your wife your wife you get
in trouble for watching porn no
no i get in trouble if i spent money to
watch
a [ __ ] my wife is very clear i probably
watch yeah i watch
porn but if if she were to go on our
bank statement
and see me running up a only fantasy
that's why you gotta go get y'all oh
[ __ ] you gotta go get you a little pipe
and [ __ ]
i mean i'm just not i'm not to be clear
like yo if they look at my business
account [ __ ]
yo why should you say only fans only
fans i'd be investing
so it's like a write-off for you thanks
you could just say that you're doing
research for girls for your videos
thanks oh tax write-off on the only fans
tax right off my only fans
yeah yeah you want to shout out your
favorite only fans accounts
give shine the lighthouse girl it's this
girl name like story they love story
nasty like what you be doing on there yo
everything is this girl named gabrielle
monique doing some nasty [ __ ] hey
nasty like when you say nasty what do
you mean you're twenties so i don't know
what nasty means to you
my my 33 year old definition of nasty
might be just off the charts it's
another girl
it's a girl her name like what
it's like a little but they nasty though
i mean look
like mr miss strokes something it's
mister and mystery
nasty tug-of-war like what's the
nastiest [ __ ] you've seen on only fans i
don't know i like that [ __ ] though
that's
we're talking like all right so boom
hold on let me just clear some up cause
they're gonna think like i got a porn
addiction hey if you do it's okay
i don't got no porn addiction cause
cause only fans isn't porn hey who just
got banned like from the nfl or
something for like
a porn addiction or something listen if
they're banning people for porn
addictions then [ __ ]
who was it someone kicked me off the
internet somebody got banned for they
but i'm telling you like yo yo real [ __ ]
sometimes i don't give [ __ ] with nobody
say sometimes porn be better than [ __ ]
well i don't dis i don't i don't
disagree with you in terms of
uh you know it's it's sometimes you know
what that should take too much energy
it's certainly
it's certainly um like you said time
consuming it's time consuming you gotta
have a girl come over then you gotta
even if you're not if you just wanna
[ __ ] you gotta make her feel good about
[ __ ] yeah
and it it's definitely too much or you
could just log on to browsers and just
you know just i don't got that though i
get you have some hack to passwords
oh you know what i used to use the hat
[ __ ] i hate
use them since in a minute listen sir
for the sake of me being videotaped
right now and
whether or not my wife watches this i
got you
[ __ ] yo i used to have all the brides
and
[ __ ] i don't got none of them hey back
in the day
bang bros browsers all that [ __ ] going
up
i used to yo i used to watch i ain't
gonna who's your favorite porn star
[ __ ]
i don't lie i ain't been watched ever
since only fans i ain't really
think of the old school ones like back
in the day uh i like sarah banks
okay you know sarah banks i know who she
is yeah i like
sarah banks i always know how old you
are based on who your favorite porn star
is
i like i like chocolate girls hey man
hey
back in the day prior to your porn
watching
uh timeline in life there was a girl
named cherokee
there was pinky i know cherokee i know
pinkie pinkie was like a [ __ ] [ __ ]
she was almost like a [ __ ] but i never
seen how big pinkie was but
she was a real short light skinned fat
ass
yes yeah everybody know lacy duvall
lacey duvall was a legend i don't know
lacy the world there was a black chick
named heather hunter who was like the
original
og she dark skin no she was like a light
but she was like the almost like the
the jenna james you know who jenna
jameson is nah so jenna jameson is like
the michael you know everybody gonna
come on and say [ __ ] so they like uh
tiana trump
oh yeah yeah tiana trump is um obviously
the hot
you know she i don't really care for her
she been popping though she alright she
went to jail and then came out like you
know [ __ ] boozy
when busy came out of jail and everybody
was she came out her [ __ ] went up
but she a lot i ain't even gonna say
that because she's gonna get talking
[ __ ] about me like i gotta watch what i
say now cause i'm a little bit bigger
hey [ __ ] it man let her fly but i was
just gonna say like [ __ ] like
well i don't know if like you know a lot
of rap [ __ ] like have [ __ ] her but
like oh a lot for sure yeah a lot of fam
okay i know she [ __ ] bill maher who's
uh he hosts a show on hbo old white man
i guess he paid her to [ __ ] what other
rap [ __ ] [ __ ] she [ __ ] trippy red
so she talked about that and then she
told me
um i'll be like i like i interviewed her
and she was talking some wild she's
[ __ ] off the chain by the way
she because she uh honey yeah and i'm
pretty sure
i'll tell you off the air there was a r
b singer
who she said that she used to [ __ ] who
who would like she would like put things
up dude's ass
oh yeah like some like and and then i
get
i guess who it was during the interview
and i i may or may not have been right i
don't want people to go find the
interview and be like that guy
but yeah i'll tell you but yeah she's
she's definitely she's all the way the
[ __ ] out here she's [ __ ] nfl players
nba players
but she ain't she fronting about i like
that exclusive [ __ ] though
good luck man i will i be finding them
though
just not on only fans see i'm young
hey let me ask you this not our only
thing bad [ __ ] on only fans wants you
to be like her male model in the video
but it's pov
so you're not in it yeah but you're
holding the camera yeah
would you do it huh
nah i can't you could you have do you
have tattoos that would like
like be the giveaway no i mean if you're
holding you know no i'm talking about
like
you got like stomach tattoos or anything
nah oh you get away with it then but see
the thing is though she's gonna come out
and be like
yeah you're right you're right you can't
trust these on yeah yeah no that ain't
me uh uh
man the [ __ ] gonna know hey i
seen some [ __ ] that went viral a
[ __ ]
kevin gates [ __ ] they said it but
he's tried to say it won't him
oh yeah that's you know man
like if you know what's crazy like if it
wasn't him
boom i like now that's hope like now
y'all have started something
like i don't like that [ __ ]